wunderschön hatte das beste zum thema
das ebit ist einer von wales wo man
überschätzt
den haben nicht mal leute gemacht wo ich
dachte die sind doof genug das zu mögen
einfach geister und wald tiefes gefühl
lass dich selig weg es ist für meinen
geschmack die mit abstand beste
konkurrenz die es jemals beim nicht
englischsprachigen film gegeben hat und
da kann florian henckel von donnersmarck
verdammt stolz sein dass er einer von
diesem film fünf kandidaten ist wie
viele ihn seine ration verabschiedet
sich vom biografischen ansatz in der
kunst und schafft so zum ersten mal in
der kunstgeschichte ein werk ohne auto
dann erst mal finde ich eigentlich eine
katastrophe
das würde einen blick auf den deutschen
film bzw insgesamt auch auf die deutsche
geschichte an die deutsche kultur
sichtbar machen den ich ganz ganz ganz
verfehlt halte was hat das mit kunst zu
tun
wodurch erhebt ist die seele was hat das
mit können zu tun denn kunst kommt von
können
ich würde sagen es wäre sehr gut wenn
donnersmarck hinbekommen würde einfach
weil wir traditionell wissen also es
geht ja nicht nur um die förderung von
einzelnen dingen sondern auch unseren
kulturpolitisches signal und ich glaube
der wird dann komplett größenwahnsinnig
und wenn deutsche künstler komplett
größen waren für das weiß man einfach
aus der vergangenheit das ist immer gut
ansonsten wäre ich mit chocolate das
extrem glücklich ist ein wunderschöner
japanischer film den ich mir viel besser
endlich gar nicht vorstellen kann
ich denke roma wird in den anderen
kategorien punkten würde mich wundern
wenn nicht oder er punkte da überhaupt
nicht an mein team sozusagen als preis
den fremdsprachigen film
liebste königin
was macht das reicht beste regie das
land muss für the favourite einfach weil
das so wahnsinnig witzig wäre wenn wir
im westen regie-preis jemand gewinnt der
komplett steht auf kamera der komplett
steht aufschnitt daher kamera und
schnitt beide auch nicht mehr gezeigt
werden was total richtig ist weil das
hatten wir uplink beistehen
deswegen gehe ich ins theater in dem
moment ins kino gehen podcast also ist
klar ja
gib uns wahre weiße männer
ich bin jetzt bei cree hat kastens einen
politischen film gemacht der gegen
gleichzeitig als keinesfalls märtyrer
film gedreht sondern als der aus der
perspektive eines selbstbewussten eines
schwarzen selbstbewusstseins dass wir in
dieser form im kino selten sie ob es
auch mein favorit ist da bin ich mir gar
nicht so hundertprozentig sicher ich
finde alfonso cuarón mit roma so
unglaublich gut in dem was er mit
bildern macht und wie er regie führt
dass er wenn es mir jetzt vor den filmen
her so am herzen liegen würde müsste er
gewinnen also für regie preises wieder
diesmal auch ausländische menschen von
der akademie ausgesehen ausländische
menschen formiert und das finde ich
super weil man muss weitermachen auf
dieser ebene auf der die neuverfilmung
von the grudge damals lief mit diesem
japanischen regisseur muss einfach nur
amerikanische schauspieler jason bär und
seine michael keller die dann kein wort
verstanden weil der nur japanisch konnte
und ich glaube da können nur bessere
filme rauskommen mein vater sagte immer
egal was du tust die 100 prozent wenn du
arbeitest arbeite wenn du lachst nacht
gelöst ist als wäre es dein letztes mal
limburg werden durch das allerschlimmste
und zwar wegen der sagt man nicht
qualität ja genau wie in der qualität
ist ein verlogener film der das
wesentliche abgesehen der rassistischen
förderung dieser beziehung sachen es
hilft also seine angestellten ist um das
es geht und keineswegs irgendwie eine
eine blühende freundschaft und
dergleichen es ist vollständiger käse
und ich bin wirklich in dem fall glaube
ich tatsächlich dass meine einschätzung
wir gewinnen sollte sich auch mit der
dect wer gewinnen wird und ich vermute
dass mit roma sein denn roma ist so
unglaublich elegant und gleichzeitig
dann auch für hollywood verhältnisse
wagemutig das ganze ist ja auch spanisch
gedreht und spielt in mexiko dass ich da
gute chancen sehe dass man sich damit
auch ein bisschen aus der politischen
affäre heraus ziehen wird und zwar auf
eine sehr anständige art thomas ganz
toll aber braucht halt kein oscar weil
es alleine so was von dermaßen ganz toll
das wissen auch alle und alle haben es
dauernd gesagt dass er kein braucht und
vielleicht deswegen daneben ein kriegt
weil die welt ist schwierig macht sich
dieser hass in der klaren rede ich nicht
auch unheimlich wütend doch natürlich
wieso tust du dann so als hättest du
damit nichts zu tun
durchhänger als seite per kernspin
gewendet erstens weil ich finde es bei
glee ist unbedingt und unbedingt und
längst fangen den westen zu gewinnen hat
es ihm damals gestohlen waren sozusagen
mit 13 und jetzt könnte das eigentlich
noch mal genauso passieren meint green
book gewinnt über wer kann da ich finde
das wirklich eigentlich kaum zum
aushalten
ich danke euch aus tiefstem herzen dass
ihr euer land niemals an die zweite
stelle setzen
beim besten film ist es wieder einen
anderen tipps für alle anderen
kategorien liebe schade es wird
überhaupt nichts anderes passieren als
dass was ich vorschlage ich muss also
nicht sagen hätte ich gern so und es
kommt aber so kommen wird es so und so
soll es auch kommen ist da is born
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn wir jetzt ermöglichen
aus dem einfachen sind weil das eine
filmmusik ist damit auch ein film über
kunst und damit auch ein film über das
kino und da wir ja alle wissen dass sie
constantin und keinen menschen auf der
welt interessiert natürlich sei nicht
nötig weil was die leute sehen wollen
sind völkermord in ruanda und hier
geschlechtliche adoptionen und so und
gegen diesen trend sich irgendwie zu
wehren das finde ich hat mindestens ein
oscar verdient und vielleicht noch ein
paar worte musik besteht nur aus zwölf
tönen innerhalb einer oktave zwölf töne
und die oktave wiederholt sich die
geschichte ist immer gleich und sie wird
wieder und wieder erzählt alles was ein
künstler der welt hier bieten kann ist
sein blick auf diese zwölf töne